die meisten von ihnen kennen mich
natürlich schon wissen warum es hier
oben stehen
ich möchte mit ihrer hilfe einen platz
in unserem gemeinderat die perfekte
kandidatin von heilmann zu ist ein
politischer film und deshalb wurde in
der vergangenen woche schon ziemlich
viel darüber geschrieben und gesprochen
denn es geht um die zustände in saudi
arabien und wie sich das land in den
letzten jahren verändert hat
die geschichte handelt von einer jungen
ärztin in einer kleinen stadt bei
regiert und die möchte sich in erster
linie dafür einsetzen dass eine
asphaltstraße als zugang zur ihrer
klinik gebaut wird damit die patienten
sicherer dort ankommen können wir sind
die einzige klinik mit einer notaufnahme
also ich meine hier in der region und
die zufahrtsstraße ist nicht aussortiert
[Musik]
also im grunde ist es ein zufall dass
dann in die politik gerät man hat keine
zeit fängt heute nur bewerber für den
gemeinderat gut dann geben sie mir einen
antrag
[Musik]
man muss ich glaube ich bei diesem film
wenn man ihn anschaut immer
vergegenwärtigen dass es in
saudi-arabien seit 2008 zehn erst wieder
kinos gibt 35 jahre lang waren die kinos
geschlossen und die regisseurin und
drehbuchautorin helfer ahlmann zu kommt
aus saudi arabien und hat eben diesen
film auch für den saudi arabischen markt
produziert und deshalb ist er so
geworden wie er jetzt ist das merkt man
ihm an
und los ich glaube unsere
sehgewohnheiten sind einfach andere wir
erwarten uns ein experiment wir erwarten
mehr überraschungen erwarten zustimmungs
aufwallungen all das ist nicht so nicht
so gegeben die die geschwindigkeit
dieses films ist auch immer gleich man
könnte das jetzt als langweilig
wahrnehmen oder oder empfinden aber es
ist glaube ich das was eben diese diese
stärke auch diese erzählkultur und diese
kultur der regisseure aus saudi arabien
sicherlich gibt es viele themen die
besonders für sie als junge frau von
großem interesse das ist richtig ich
wenn ich bin ärzten so was mir die
grünanlagen wie sieht es aus mit
spielplatz eisermann zu hatten 2012
einen film in saudi arabien gedreht der
heißt das mädchen und handelt von einem
kind was ein rad geschenkt bekommen
möchte viele jungs als freunde und
verstehe einfach nicht warum sie jetzt
also warum das mädchen warum sie jetzt
nicht rad fahren darf und das hat schon
eine kontroverse ausgelöst
und was jetzt kommt eben acht jahre
später reflektiert auch so ein bisschen
das was in diesen jahren sich verändert
hat frauen dürfen jetzt auto fahren
frauen dürfen reisen ohne die
einverständniserklärung eines vormundes
sie dürfen hotels besuchen an strände
gehen dh der kronprinz hat politisch
ziemlich viel verändert in diesem land
aber diese veränderung ist in der
gesellschaft eben noch nicht so richtig
angekommen
das heißt es ist nicht so dass dieses
land auf einen idealen weg ist aber es
verändert sich eben vieles und das wird
in dem film sehr schön abzug genauso wie
ich bin kandidaten an
und so einer person begegnet man mit
dustin ob sie nun mann oder frau
wir lassen uns von frauen nicht sagen
keine frauen ansonsten ist der film ein
film der leisen töne also ein film ohne
große experimente sowohl technische als
auch ex erzählerischer art aber man
kommt der kultur sehr nahe also wenn man
die saudi arabische kultur etwas näher
kennen lernen will ist es ist ein guter
weg ist die unsere calida ein heimlicher
frei
was du hier machst wenn man jetzt
parallelen aufmachen wollte zu filmen
die in letzter zeit in unserem
kulturkreis entstanden sind und
veröffentlicht wurden kann man es schon
gewissermaßen mit little women von greta
gerwig vergleichen
das sind auch junge frauen die
miteinander an einem gemeinsamen projekt
arbeiten kämpfen sich durch lavieren
durch durch schwierige situationen und
eben auch frauen bündnisse eingehen und
daraus gestärkt hervorgehen ansonsten
würde ich empfehlen also wer auch immer
sich für die arabische kultur
interessiert sollte sich diesen film
anschauen das ist es gibt viel über
musiktraditionen über über kulturelle
gepflogenheiten und zu lernen und es ist
auch eine starke geschichte für eine für
für drei schwestern geschwisterliebe und
was man alles tut um das fortkommen und
und und den erfolg seiner seine
geschwister zu sichern
das krankenhaus in dem frauen arbeiten
bringt nichts ein
ich zeige ihnen was ich kann